for the past two decades I cannot see
the title Dungeons and Dragons or hear
it and not think of that classic audio
comedy Dungeons and Dragons
Satan's game and I figured I'd start
this video out by blowing your mind
taking you back to the Napster days but
we got a new DND movie to talk about so
let's do it
so Dungeons and Dragons honor among
Thieves is a new fantasy comedy based
off of the popular role-playing game and
I had no care for a new dungeons of
dragons movie Zero [__] given I I don't
even think I think I might have seen one
trailer back in the day
but no more what can I say I was there
over two decades ago when the previous d
d movie came out all my friends and I
were all pumped and well that well it
happened the way it happens and I guess
that just changed me which is completely
unfair new creative team this movie's
not even linked to that movie it's
unfair to be like that movie from a
couple decades sucked so I'm not gonna
look forward to this movie what can I
say it's just just how it was and to my
surprise this movie was a shh
[Music]
fuckingly enjoyable time first of all
you have Chris Pine leading this film
for what this movie is that is perfect
it's perfect casting for a league
because Chris Pine comes across as
naturally charmingly funny it doesn't
ever feel like he's trying there are
people who say funny things and there
are people who say things funny for
example Hugh Grant in this movie it does
feel like Hugh Grant is scripted to say
funny things you can almost see the
director be like okay now do a quirky
yeah that's the energy we're going for
perfect he's saying funny things because
he needs to in this fantasy Adventure
comedy Chris Pine just comes across as
saying things funny he's just naturally
being Chris Pine and is working the
script can be bad guy we are taking her
to the castle good guy wait where are
you taking her with most people it'd be
like we're taking her to the castle
where are you taking her with Chris Pine
is like we're taking her to the castle
oh good wait where are you taking her
for this movie and what the vibe the
movie was going for Chris Pine
absolutely worked that is Mary band of
Misfits work too it's good of amusing to
me that we're we're done with the age of
the of the super strong like yes the
warrior the Paladin is absolutely the
lead good guy not Chris Pine's The Bard
you have a mage Barbarian you do have a
paladin that comes in for a bit they do
come across as a group of we shouldn't
be the last best hope but we are
so we're just gonna do our thing and in
fact it's not to do the thing Chris
Pine's trying to save his daughter which
is a fun flip on the whole Save The
Princess and the castle thing and when
thinking about it maybe I'm just looking
for excuses I I don't know but in full
transparency it's absolutely possible
but the banter that they have in this
movie and making this a fun
a friendly banter comedy I guess it's
the term not a real genre but I'ma say
it that way it does have that Vibe of
the kind of banter friends would have
when they're around a table playing DND
granted it didn't need to be that way
for that reason right when the Warhammer
series comes out I want the dark gritty
lore-based world that I like about
Warhammer because friends play it around
a table I don't need a banter comedy or
someone's like all right can you hit him
I can but uh all right I think I have
line of sight it's on his shoulder this
this shot's gonna kill him because it
hits his shoulder what no you don't have
line of sight yeah I do here check it
all right well it's not really a line of
size totally line of sight I can hit his
shoulder no you can't well I can hit his
toe that counts too I don't need
dialogue like that though it is a thing
it's the kind of dialogue and banter
that happens when people play Warhammer
there's even this one scene where
someone's listing off everything they
need to do to get across this problem it
just sounds like a DM listing off the
overly complicated rules that the
players need to do to to solve this
problem I couldn't help but see that
scene see the banter and feel like oh
that's why they went for this Vibe they
like the vibe of friends around a table
playing d d though it they're not around
the table they're in the world which is
how it's supposed to feel when you play
DND you have an active imagination so
there is that that might act as a
double-edged sword though they're people
who watch this movie I know they're DND
fans are like yeah that's it was
actually pretty cool because that's how
it feels there might be other folks out
there who will be like it's D and D I
love d d I was hoping for the next Lord
of the Rings come on this is not that
it's not the next Lord of the Rings
though to be fair I don't think
audiences anywhere ever thought it could
be or would be the CGI in this movie is
absolutely ass which is another funny
thing it's like hey it's an action
comedy with [__] CGI sounds like we're
talking about recent MCU I usually give
the MCU scrutiny for that but all things
not being equal I just I don't as much
for this movie because Dungeons and
Dragons honor among Thieves isn't the
biggest cinematic property in the
history of movies backed by the biggest
Studio feels like an underdog so it's
like all right you have [__] CGI I get
it you didn't have an unlimited budget
whatever kind of like in high school but
I got a B on a test the teacher was like
Jeremy you got a B so good to see that
you actually studied for this test it
looks like that studying is paying off
good job but if the straight A student
got a B you'd be like is everything okay
is a
do you need to talk to a counselor and
this movie is a bit too long could have
shaped 15 minutes easy but in the end
Dungeons and Dragons honor among Thieves
it surprised me it's a fun fantasy
Adventure comedy with endearing
characters actually had a pretty solid
Heist segment in here too that I felt
was the strongest part of the entire
thing actually second to the movie's
core and to its core it does have a
heartfelt family dynamic in here I
really appreciate it I rarely bring up
ratings but it's rated PG-13 I bring it
up because it's in that Revenge of the
Sith kind of way where it's like well
it's not the hardest PG-13 I've ever
seen that is to say if you and your
family you're looking for a nice time
out at the movies this movie comes out
at the end of the month I feel like this
is a good one it was a fun time no
alcohol required all right so Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves have you
seen it what did you think about it or
do you play D and D what's your class do
you cast magic Missile and do you attack
the darkness whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]